hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
i think that many of us are interested
in trying to do the right
thing in various contexts but as we
learn from spike lee's movie
as well as elsewhere it can be hard to
know what it means
to do the right thing and that's true
both in a narrow sense and in a
meta sense in a literal sense we don't
know what
which thing to do is the right one
that's what spike lee
investigated but the metasense is what
does it
mean to say that something is the right
thing so there literally is within
uh philosophy the study of ethics and
moral philosophy
but then there's the study of meta
ethics what are the standards by which
we defend a certain conception
of what is morally right i myself
subscribe to something called
moral constructivism where i think that
what exists out there in the world
is the natural world stuff behaving in
certain ways in accordance with the laws
of physics
morality i think is something that we
human beings or presumably other
conscious creatures
out there in the cosmos talk about and
construct
ourselves and then it's very interesting
to talk about well
what things should we construct how
should we decide to be moral and
different people disagree and so forth
but i think that my point of view there
is a minority one i think that most
people
both both on the street and professional
thinkers about this
are what we call moral realists they
think that in
addition to the physical stuff of the
universe there is something else
some way of judging what is right and
wrong it might come from
god if you're religious or it might come
from philosophizing
from pure rationality or might just come
from sort of
introspecting about our intuitions about
what is right
and what is wrong so today's guest is
russ schaefer landau he's one of the
best people to talk about these issues
he's a one of the leading defenders of
moral realism
among his many books are called moral
realism a defense
which is a long scholarly philosophical
tone where you can really get into the
weeds
but he's also written a shorter book
called whatever happened to good and
evil if you want sort of the
immediate catchy version of this kind of
argument
so russ is a non-naturalist about
morality
but not a theist about morality in other
words he thinks that there is something
to the world that is objectively there
which you can call morality
but not that it comes from god or
anything like that and as he articulates
in the interview he's much more about
understanding what our intuitions tell
us
thinking that that gives us some access
to something real which helps us decide
what is good
and what is evil so i don't agree with
that but we had a great conversation
because russ is really really good
both about understanding the opposite
point of view and about understanding
the weakness in his own point of view
i think that kind of approach actually
makes it a lot more convincing to people
who are
skeptics i'm not completely convinced
but i think this is a very very
important debate discussion to have
morality is something where a lot of
people think that you know
they can figure it out given 10 minutes
of careful contemplation right how hard
can it be
i think it's very hard and i think it's
something that deserves careful
contemplation
more careful than just sitting around
for a few minutes deciding oh yeah i got
it now i know what's right
and what's wrong let me also before we
dive into it uh give a short
plug for an organization that actually
an organization here at caltech where i
am the academic advisor for a student
group called
caltech letters you can visit them at
caltechletters.org
and it's a it's basically a journal an
online journal where they
publish articles about science but then
also viewpoint articles
essays and they started a couple of
podcasts that i think
are very interesting so they have a
podcast called not my thesis
where they explore the unpublished parts
of the scientific
process the stuff that does not go into
technical journal articles
and there's another new podcast they're
doing called biosphere
which explores how we fit into the
living world
especially from the perspective of
biology phd students
they're they're really really uh sharply
focused on not just putting something
out there in the world
at caltech letters but really making it
high quality these are
more than just offhand remarks they're
very highly polished edited
pieces which i think provoke a lot of
thought in good ways so give them a
visit at caltechletters.org
and with that let's go
[Music]
russia for landau welcome to the
mindscape podcast happy to be here
so this is one in a tradition it's not
like a hugely represented tradition but
i like to have people on the podcast who
i disagree with
but i can disagree with in a way that i
think that uh we have something to learn
from them so you know i don't go for the
flat earthers i go for the people who
are
having respectable opinions that that i
disagree with and
my uh attitude in these episodes is that
i i am
absolutely here to give you the chance
to put the best foot forward for your
case i'll try to let my
objections be known and maybe you'll
even change my mind who knows
but we're mostly here to have you state
your case and so
in this case the case is
moral realism uh which is something so
i'm i'm not i'm a moral anti-realist i
guess
but why don't you for the people who are
not experts in the listening audience
out there
how about the lay of the land you know
what is the landscape when it comes to
what different possible attitudes one
could have toward i guess
meta ethics is the right uh field that
we're in here
that's right so we are in meta ethics
and just to
situate folks at at one remove
meta ethics is not trying to it is a
branch of moral philosophy but it's not
trying to answer questions about what
actually is right or wrong or good or
bad
rather it's trying to take a step back
and ask about the nature
of moral reality if there is one
how we can know it if we can
what the nature of moral judgments are
are they
more like straight-up beliefs or are
they more desire-like
states questions like that so within
metaethics
there's a bunch of different ways of
carving up the terrain but here's one
and you might think there are
three really big families of views
one's a view that we can call nihilism
uh philosophers don't use that term that
much but it's
designed to cover all the views that say
there's no moral reality really um
some some versions of nihilism say you
know we most of us
think there is but we're just mistaken
in the way that
an atheist say will diagnose religious
belief and religious discourse
lots and lots of folks out there believe
in it but there is some fundamental
presupposition
that infects the the whole picture and
really there's nothing to it
that's one view you might have about
morality then another view is a view
according to which there
is a moral reality but the reality
is a constructed one these folks are
called constructivists
unsurprisingly and the one analogy
is uh between say morality and the law
or morality and etiquette where you
might say
that really you know if you drive 50
miles now or
in a 20 mile an hour zone you'd say yeah
that was really that was illegal
and it's you know and if if someone says
that was illegal you could say
yeah what what that person just said is
true and
there's and you can tell a story in
epistemology about how you come to know
that truth
and you might think well morality is is
uh more or less
like the law or like the etiquette in
that
before human beings came on the scene
there wasn't any such thing
but for various reasons and of course
different constructivists will tell
different stories
um it did come on the scene uh
with us and uh it's a constructed
it's a social it's a social construction
it can be quite complex but at bottom if
you ask where does morality come from
the answer is it comes from the
decisions or the attitudes
of human beings either singly that's the
kind of subjectivism
or collectively which
typically yields a form of relativism it
doesn't have to but it can
and then lastly there's uh the family of
views known as moral realism
which says there is you know there's a
moral reality out
there hence moral realism but the
reality is not a constructed one it's
not
one that's made up by human beings
either singly or collectively either
by reference to their actual
or by reference some cleaned up
hypothetical
idealized version of the judgments that
we would have
rather morality moral principles say
moral standards are quote unquote out
there
in a pretty robustly objective way they
await our discovery
um we've invented the vocabulary uh
to describe these things as good or bad
vicious or virtuous things like that
but the truths that we
are apprehending uh are not of our own
making
so and then within moral realism because
you know we're doing philosophy here
there are lots of other subjects
categories yeah
yeah lots of different versions of of
more realism but
that's that's basically the lay of the
land
and you're going to be in the more
realism camp there just so we i am going
to be in a more realism camp and and
within the more realism camp i'm going
to be
in what's called the non-naturalist camp
so within realism itself
there there are a bunch of different
divisions but the main division
at least within the last say 120 years
has been between those who think of
themselves as naturalists and those who
don't
a naturalist is someone who thinks of
morality
as uh on a par with
other naturalistic disciplines in
particular the natural sciences
may not be as advanced in its findings
as the natural sciences but the basic
methodologies of discovering
what's right and wrong mirror the basic
methodologies
of the natural sciences the reality that
awaits our discovery
is continuous with the reality
it's a kind of natural scientific
reality
and then there's on the other side the
so-called non-naturalist it's not a very
catchy term
but it's uh that and and that's where i
place myself it's folks who think that
moral realism is true there's a robustly
objective moral reality
but morality is relevant is not really
like the sciences no matter how much
scientific investigation we do
we're not going to be we can be
certainly aided
in discovering what's right and wrong by
by reference to that
but the truths aren't scientific ones
the methodology
is not we don't go to a lab we don't
need to go to a lab we don't need to run
actual controlled experiments on actual
populations
to make a determination about say the
immorality of genocide
so folks on in my
little niche of the meta ethical world
uh
are usually the ones who are subject to
the most
either ridiculed depending on your
attitude at the time
or the most criticism uh among the the
realist camp because
what you know you could see the
attraction of being in that if
you know there are issues to do with
realism about realism of course in the
first place that turn a lot of people
off
but if you're attempted to the realist
view a lot of folks
go naturalistic because they think it's
metaphysically respectable
you know if you think of morality as
just another kind of
natural phenomenon then you don't have
to introduce
these non-scientific features
properties in the world and that's that
leads to a more economical
metaphysically economical picture
that's quite attractive to a lot of
people i definitely want to excuse me
dig into the
non-naturalism aspect of things uh in
some detail here but first
uh i'm sure that some of the people in
the audience have
mostly confronted or experienced the
idea of non-naturalism as
theism right as that's the you know you
contrast naturalism with theism but
you're doing something different here
yeah that's a really good question and
you're certainly right about the
presuppositions
in in the canonical text
uh called principia ethica by a british
philosopher g e moore
that came out in 1903 he just he was the
one who coined the term non-naturalism
and who and uh he distinguished
naturalism from non-naturalism but also
from supernaturalism
and that distinction has been within
philosophy at least
pretty much pretty uh honored over the
last 100 roughly 120 years
there's a very common thought among
non-philosophers that if you're going to
take up with a view like mine you've got
to
ground morality in some kind of
divine command or some kind of divine
agency but that's
i think that's just a mistake i think uh
and
even for those who believe that it's uh
the best version of realism
is going to be one that uh is founded
in in some reference to god
they recognize at least the coherence
and the intelligibility
of a view of the sort that i hold which
is
not a theistic one yeah okay good i mean
maybe before
actually explicating what that view is
you can give us a hint just so i think
that this is
let me let me back up a little bit i
know for a fact
that when you talk about things like
morality one of the issues
that the discourse runs into is that
people have pre-existing ideas right
so it's not like talking about the higgs
boson where i can just explain things
and people go oh yes but
everyone has their own little idea so
why don't you just give us a preview
about
why you believe this particular view
called uh
moral moral realism from the
non-naturalist perspective
sure um well i'll take it in two steps
one is
why do i believe moral realism and then
why do i favor the non-naturalism is
that okay
like that yeah okay so here's um
why moral realism well if you think back
to the taxonomy i gave
earlier one way to see the attractions
of more realism is by seeing what's
problematic with
the opponents it's it's not this is not
necessarily just an
it's not necessarily an argument from
elimination but it helps to
put the attractions of realism into
sharp focus i think
so if you've got a nihilist version
i think i myself think that's a version
of last resort
uh i would think that of course but i
invite
those who aren't antecedently inclined
the way i am
to just think about the implications of
a view according to which
we can take a big example uh one i used
earlier
according to which there really is
nothing immoral about perpetrating
genocide
or there or to take a smaller example
but one that hopefully is
just as clear annihilus is committed to
saying there's nothing wrong with
deliberately
um accosting a vulnerable little kid and
then
smacking the kid as hard as you can and
laughing at the kid
right as he as he you know falls down
the puddle of tears
to me i think that when doing philosophy
there's no there's no alternative but to
rely
at various junctures on our intuitions
we can talk about that uh because that
that self is a philosophically
controversial
claim but that's my view at least and
i think that some of our moral
intuitions about cases of this
like the two i've just described are as
clear and as probative actually
as any kind of evidence we can have in
philosophy
so if you've taken nihilistic kind of
view
you've got to give up on that source
of knowledge and my my thought is if you
have to give it up
when it comes to morality you're going
to need to give it up
all over the place in philosophy and
that's going to lead to
that's going to lead to an insuperable
difficulty about gaining philosophical
knowledge insight wisdom and
understanding
so just to summarize your your main
objection to nihilism
is just that it is in conflict with our
intuitions
that's right and and the substance of
our intuitions
so i you know just just invite someone
to say
with a straight face there's nothing
wrong at all about perpetrating the
sorts of acts
i've done you know i've just described
and
i know a number of smart people who are
also really nice people by the way
uh who who can say that with a straight
face
i i know most of those in the
philosophical community who can do that
but i think that uh
it's it comes at very high cost well i'm
not i guess i'm not a nihilist myself
i'm more of a constructivist but
just to you know do a little bit of um
standing up for them i mean couldn't
isn't
can i restate your argument or or try to
um
put it in slightly different terms by
saying it's not that
the fact that we seem to have intuitions
that overrides them such as that
they still are acting as if there is
morality like you said there are nice
people people who behave well and
therefore there must be some internal
incoherence or inconsistency
in a nice nihilism like alex rosenberg
who was a previous
guest on the podcast he proudly
proclaims himself to be a nice
nihilist yeah i
i myself actually don't think there's
any inconsistency in being a nice
nihilist
uh i that's that's a charge i hear
sometimes from my students
when i introduce them to this idea but
in fact i think you can be a perfectly
coherent
nice nihilist okay um and and also you
can be perfectly coherent nihilist and
say
look i think it's a really terrible idea
to to perpetrate genocide or to smack
kids just because you know just when
you're angry
uh and that's also coherent right all
they
all they're forbidden from saying so to
speak uh
so is to maintain consistency is to say
that their preferences
uh register some kind of genuine
immorality
or reality so you can say look it would
be a better thing for everybody not
morally better
but people would be happier or less
unhappy if we acted this way
and that's a perfectly consistent thing
for nihilus to say
got it okay so let's move on to knocking
down constructivism then
well my big you know there are lots of
forms of constructivism but here's my
big beef
with constructivism and that is it i
don't think
that i have i don't think that my say-so
makes it so when it comes to morality i
don't have that kind of authority
i mean i've been doing moral philosophy
for 30 years
i'm not terrible at it i'm not the best
at it for sure
but uh my say but let's take the person
who is
you know let's let's focus on people who
are among the very
best moral philosophers ever it's still
the case i think that
their say so doesn't make it so we are
each one of us either individually or
taken together is fallible
in the in a whole range of ways we're
imperfect we've got our biases sometimes
they're known sometimes they're unknown
we're in in terms of
processing information we all are
limited in various ways
we all have our tendentious
prejudices some of which were unaware
others of which were aware but we can't
fully correct for
all these things come into play in in
making
moral judgments uh and i don't see
how how it can be that any of us can
have the requisite authority
to be such that it's our attitudes or
our agreements or our judgments
that are the ultimate source of morality
i guess i just say one one more thing to
back that up
i'd extend this argument all the way to
a critique of
so-called divine command theory
according to which
you have god who's who's perfect
all-knowing
at least making the the decisions
about what's right and wrong so the
divine command theory says what's right
is right if and only if and because
god commands it wrong if and only and
because
god forbids it i think even that kind of
view is problematic even so
if even god i mean we could talk about
reasons why if you want but
uh if even gods say so doesn't make it
so
then surely we imperfect
puny little uh fallible human beings say
so
isn't going to make it so either well
but uh as a constructivist i don't want
to spend too much time like i said uh
sort of defending my own point of view
here but my my immediate
uh feeling about that would be that
somehow it's begging the question
uh that you that you're that kind of
analysis
seems to rely on the idea that there is
an objectively true statement about what
morality is
and then then i would agree that we
fallible human beings are not
necessarily
the right place to find that with
perfect precision but
if you buy the analogy the morality is
more like
the laws of speeding or the rules of
playing basketball that are
constructed then there's no such thing
as the perfect rules for playing
basketball but there's nevertheless what
we make up
great that's ab that's you're absolutely
right and then
uh just to take it to the next level of
analysis i just
invite you to think about the
implications of that kind of view
so i don't know what kind of
constructivist you are whether you think
that
moral principles uh correct moral
principles are ultimately founded in
each individual's
attitudes or whether it's a group effort
do you want to do you want to i think
it's anything about it yeah and i mean i
very roughly think that um there is a
job for moral philosophy
namely to take the moral intuitions that
individuals have
and to listen to individuals talk to
each other and try to rationally
describe what their goals are and
from that to construct something that
might not be objective and might not be
uh settled and permanent but is
provisionally what we take to be
good moral behavior yeah okay so
on on that kind of view to me the
problem is that
what seems what has seemed to a bunch of
folks to be
a cogent set of a cogent moral outlook
after reflection strikes
me as deeply problematic and you might
say well russ
isn't that kind of arrogant uh you know
how
why are you russ the arbiter of what's
right and wrong and i want to first i
want to
claim my own fallibility here but
if you if you take a look at this kind
of constructivist position what it's
going to do is
is it's going to say that in societies
or among groups
when across societies what you know
however you're imagining
this to go if they were to
make a determination after reflection
that
you know it's okay to make women
second-class citizens
it's okay to enslave a certain portion
of the population
either because their skin color because
their beliefs are because they're
geographically
whatever it is then constructivism says
morally speaking that's that's right and
that's that's an implication that
i i find i just can't stomach
if you're interested in learning new
things one great place to go is the
great courses plus
a streaming service that brings you high
level courses in a variety of topics
from some of the best professors out
there you can learn to become a great
writer you can practice mindfulness or
you can learn a bit of astrophysics
and with the great courses plus app it's
extremely convenient you can learn from
anytime
anywhere on your tv on your mobile
device or what have you
if you're interested in the kind of
philosophical questions we're talking
about in today's episode
you might want to try a course called
understanding the dark side of human
nature by professor daniel breyer
it's all about why sometimes human
beings are not that moral
are we fundamentally good fundamentally
evil what makes us
do bad things we can learn about this in
the comfort of your home with your
family or all by yourself
so sign up for the great courses plus
today and mindscape listeners
can get a free trial with unlimited
access to the entire
library start that free trial today at
thegreatcoursesplus.com
mindscape that's t-h-e great courses
p-l-u-s dot com slash mindscape
right and i think that that's a
perfectly fair i think that as a
constructivist
you have to bite that bullet and you
have to say yes like
the process of constructing in different
places and in different times
might come up with things that i sean
who i'm also not
the ultimate moral arbiter uh think are
horrible and so and i would try to
argue those people out of it based on
whatever common moral intuitions we have
uh and i think that the as a
philosophical argument against
constructivism
that argument really only works if again
you kind of assume there is an
objective ultimate right and wrong and
then you're saying but this method isn't
getting it
but if i don't assume that it's an
objective right and wrong then this is
the method that we have
yeah well i agree that this is the i
agree actually that this is a method
that we have whether constructivism or
realism
is correct where the method we have
refers to
how it is that we're going to engage in
discussions with people who don't
antecedently share
our views the only way the only way you
can try to make progress there i think
is to appeal to things that your
that your discussion partner some things
that they're already going to be
at least open to hearing and ideally
will accept
if you can find some shared basis from
which to work you're much likelier to
get
to consensus at the end and that's true
like you know whether constructivism is
correct or whether realism is correct
but i also want to think i also think
that this scenario
is plausible namely that some people are
mistaken
and can't be shown the error of their
ways
i think that that's a general truth um
it's it's true about flat earthers for
instance
and don't need to tell me yeah i i
i'm sure i don't um but i also think
that's the case in morality
i think that some people uh you know we
have examples
in our in our public life right now i'm
not gonna name names
we've got examples of people who just
won't see reality for what it is let's
forget about moral reality for right now
and there are a whole lot of
explanations
plausible ones for why that is
self-interest being among them but not
the only one
ideological indoctrination being another
and i think that these
these forces carry over into morality as
well
it's possible for someone to just be
blind
to the moral equality of a woman
or an african-american and there's
nothing you can say
and furthermore there might be no film
they're willing to watch
or memoir or narrative they're willing
to read
and even if they do read them they may
bring their blind or
what i'd call what you'd say i'd be
tendentiously calling their blinders
to to the reading or to the film
watching and they may be unconvinced in
the end
now there are two diagnoses to make from
that one is a constructivist one which
says
you know if at the end of the
conversation the person is not persuaded
then there's no moral reality that
they're missing
my my view is that they might well be
missing something
and furthermore i this is this is
the flip side of the point i've just
make been making
it's actually much harder on a
constructivist view to maintain
uh an attitude of fallibility
than it is on the realist view so
it's it's harder to say what you did i
know i'm doing all the talking so i
i know you're here to talk please yeah
um it's harder to say what you said
three or four minutes ago uh from a
constructivist point of view than a
realist point of view what you
and what i'm referring to is your
profession
your admirable profession of fallibility
and humility
about things if it can if constructivism
is true
then i'm not saying this is your view
but let's just take a simple
kind of relativist view about morality
according to which
morality is grounded in some kind of
social or cultural consensus
right um whatever follows from the from
the deep
morays of a culture or society is what's
morally right
in that on that picture here's what you
need in order to know what's right and
wrong
you need to know what your society
stands for or what your culture stands
for
as long as you do and you're not
benighted
about the the relevant empirical facts
on the ground
then you've got moral knowledge if your
culture is built on
a rejection of the equality of women and
men if your culture is built on
the view that women are there or have
been
have are here to serve men
that's one of the founding ideals the
culture then so long as you know that
and subscribe to it and can see how that
plays out
in the ordinary say domestic lives of
women
and you then it turns out
you know a woman's place morally
speaking you know
a woman's place and that is to serve her
man or her men
i think that not only is the the moral
implication of that
repugnant but i think that it makes
moral knowledge actually too easy to get
i think
i know i think if you were to say
well russ that assumes that's
tententious that assumes that there's an
objective morality
that these folks are straying from and
it assumes that there's an objective
morality that might be more difficult to
get
than than by means of the sort of
sociological knowledge i've just
described
that's that's the consistent thing to
say and i
so i'm not going to say anything that's
going to
indict constructivists on
on the grounds that they are necessarily
inconse have an
inconsistent view you can definitely
coherently
build up and construct any number of
constructivist views
i'm just pointed to implications that i
that
repugnant is a strong word but with
regard to that particular conclusion
it's it's one that i do find repugnant
and um you know uh
i think there's no there's no easy way
out of that conclusion two conclusions
really one is that
when you think about the actual
substantive moral implications of a view
like
that kind of relativism i think they're
very hard to stomach
the second conclusion which is the the
one i
should have really been focusing on is
the point that
if you're a constructivist it makes
perhaps paradoxically it makes moral
knowledge too easy to get
most people don't think that that could
be a problem with a moral view
but i do think it's a problem with a
moral view i think that
the the intellectual virtues of modesty
and humility the recognition of your own
fallibility
sit best with a realist view i mean
you're a physicist
what's the right attitude for physicists
to take about
you know about the cosmos it's humility
and a recognition of fallibility and
modesty
and the re and the explanation of why
those are the appropriate attitudes to
take is because
you don't get to make up the truth
you're there to discover a truth not of
your own making
i think the same is i think the same is
the case when it comes to morality
if you're a moral realist you ought to
be
humble about your moral opinions and
modest in the in
in their expression because you hold the
view that there is a moral reality
out there that's not of your own making
and yet some of my best friends are
physicists and cosmologists and not all
of them are characterized by enormous
amounts of humility interestingly
interestingly enough no i completely i
think that
i more or less agree with everything
you're saying as i said i think that the
constructivist has to bite the bullet
about the fact that
even in good faith and we can come up
with less repugnant
uh versions of the fact that um
people thinking in good faith either
individuals or groups of individuals
societies
might end up constructing versions of
morality that i find
deeply distasteful and that's something
that the constructivist has to live with
on the other side the constructivist is
going to say
but well so one version of
constructivism might say
but the world is out there and it does
things and i can do experiments on
it and morality is not out there so you
moral realist
why don't you make the positive case for
uh something that is objectively true
there
oh good thanks uh so
one uh my naturalist
realist brethren will do that in one way
and i'll do it in a different way the
naturalist will
will go out and say yeah we can do um
experiments of a kind uh
because moral facts are just a species
of natural fact
and that's that's not my kind of view
um i think one important reason to hold
the sort of non-naturalist view i do
uh and it's the one that sets it up for
criticism
uh i mean there are a lot of elements in
my view that set up for criticism but
this one is
something that was just beneath the
surface in the conversation we've been
having over the last 10 or 15 minutes
and that is a commitment to what i'll
call the
normative authority of morality if you
and the way i can
perhaps the best way explain that is by
contrast with the view that you've been
uh you've been advocating so if you take
this is not to do down constructivism
but just to highlight what i regard as a
feature of non-naturalism
and as suppose you've got a view of
constructivism the sort that you've just
been describing
and you and you're led to say uh
well yeah some people do it this way
some people do it that way
these different ways are just different
they're not
better or worse than one another to at
least so long as they're equally
coherent
because there's no objective measure by
which to measure
the superiority or inferiority of one
moral in one coherent moral code
over another but and then that leads as
you've
for forthrightly allowed that leads you
to say well
so if you've got a morality that
condones female inferiority
or chattel slavery i'm going to try to
argue them out of it
but i can't say that that moral view is
inferior to mine it's just
different from mine if you got
i'm not now focusing on what i regard as
the problematic nature of that
implication but instead
a different one and that is it if you've
got a view like that then it seems to
sap
morality of what i call norm of
normative authority normative is just a
fancy word that philosophers use to do
with
like reason giving i think that there
are powerful reasons to comply with
moral
requirements and moral prohibitions but
if you have a view
according to which morality is created
by us
and for us then those reasons may be
either strongly diminished or in fact
non-existent
if you think about it think about the
simple sort of cultural relativism
that i was discussing earlier according
to which
morality is a cultural byproduct
morality is just that set of norms
that are either directly endorsed by a
culture
or that are implied by those
endorsements
then you might say well imagine you're
an iconoclast in the culture
that is very inegalitarian very
intolerant and you say you know what
my parents believe that we should treat
these other folks as
inferiors everybody all my neighbors do
and that's what my teacher taught me but
i think that all human beings are at a
fundamental level
moral equals to one another and their
skin color their sex their gender their
religious beliefs
that's irrelevant in the determination
of how much respect
and dignity a person deserves
suppose you had an iconoclast who
believed something like that
on the version of relativism i'm
describing that that
that person would be making a very deep
moral error
leave that now leave that implication
aside and focus
on this authority point that i'm i'm
trying to highlight here
what i would say is that if i were that
sort of iconoclast or you or anybody
else
i'd scratch my head and say why should i
do
what my culture says and someone might
say
well because that's what morality is
and i'd say you know what it seems then
that i don't have any reason to adhere
to morality
because it's just you know it's a it's
it's an expression it's a normative
system
that results from an expression of
uninformed prejudices
and so i don't have any reason to comply
with it i mean i might have a practical
reason
i'll get put in jail or otherwise
condemned
but those sorts of reasons aside what
you know what non-self-interested reason
might i have to comply with it and i
think the answer in that case is
none i want i you know the vision of
morality that i would
i am hoping is is correct uh
is one according to which if something
is morally required of you
then that carries with the genuine
non-self-interested kind of
practical authority the way they called
normative authority there there are
genuine
reasons to comply with that even if you
don't like it
even if it doesn't meet up with your
expectations or hopes or your interests
or needs if something is morally
required of you then there's reason to
do that
naturalist realists in fact naturalists
of all stripes
have had great difficulty making sense
of that thought there's account i should
i should say accounting for that thought
within their theories
and they've some of them have tried
gallantly to accommodate that thought
but most have been led to say you know
what morality doesn't have any special
authority over us after all
let's let me just uh interject a little
bit because i want to get two things on
the table very very quickly
before we pass on to other more
interesting things but um
number one i should have said from the
start that i entirely
appreciate the attraction of moral
realism in the sense that there are
objective rules and that would be great
if there were objective rules so you
know i feel
sad that i i'm not a moral realist even
though
i think that's the right thing to do but
the other is that i i do
like and i'm not sure if this is
respectable or not but i do hold this
view that there is um a distinction
between the kind of relativism
that says well that culture over there
has its own rules
they're not mine but there's nothing i
can say about them because
they're theirs and the kind of
constructivism that says
each individual society or culture
whatever is constructing its own rules
but i have every right to judge the
other ones by my standards i can say
that your
set of moral rules that you've
constructed are not
objectively wrong but i still feel
sincerely and honestly that they're not
the ones you
should have and i'm not going to
abandon my right or ability to either
judge you badly or try to talk you out
of them
good and i take it that the the latter
view is the one that you'd endorse
yes that's right yeah and good because
it's better than the first few but still
i'd say problematic
i just want to let it know that that is
a view you don't have to just be
a screaming relativist and say well
whatever different societies want to say
that's fine i can't judge them i want to
keep my ability to be judgey that's all
i want
you got it but then the question of
course is that when you make a judgment
you do it by reference to some standard
and then
if someone says they could they could
put it this way
uh who are you to judge sure to which
you have a great answer
i'm a person of you know with a critical
faculty and critical intelligence
who you know who's become acquainted
with your culture and
and your ways and on that basis
i'm judging you but then right but then
there's a next step and that is to say
are the standards by reference to which
you're rendering your judgments
are those standards in any way morally
superior to the standards of my own
society
and that's something that's i think
going to be very hard for you to answer
i mean you can say yeah they are
superior but you're saying that by
reference to
your society's own standards and so that
looks pretty question begging
uh which you know to the extent that
things are question bet claims are
question begging that's
that's a problem uh the realist of
course doesn't face that but the realist
does
of course face lots of other objections
like you know
exactly so i'm not even going to try to
defend myself i still want to get to the
the
your positive uh realist okay good so
there are lots of different ways of
trying to defend realism
the way that i've come to do it
is is informed i should say by
a years long project and i'm still
involved in with two other philosophers
my colleague at uw maz and john benson
and a colleague at the university of
vermont terence cuneo
we were writing three books uh it
started out as one big book
and it's now three uh three books and
one of the books a short one
is on methodology and philosophy
and i i'm one of the folks who's
responsible for developing this
methodology and so
the in a nutshell what the methodology
tells us is that the way to make
progress
in gaining understanding of a given
area of law and philosophy is by first
trying to identify the data within that
domain
and then constructing theories that have
to meet various criteria
of adequacy in uh that attempt to
account for that data in ethics there
are a lot of data
that we either have to account for
or have to explain away and of course
it's it's going to be a philosophically
controversial matter
which of these data stand the test
and which of these data ought to be
tossed aside but one of the big benefits
of moral realism which has been it's
which has been recognized for a while
but it's never been i don't think been
put
quite this way is it when it comes to
the data of ethics moral realism does a
fantastic job
of accounting for them so the data have
to do with things like
uh our the possibility that
some moral views are true and some are
false the possibility that some people
are morally wiser
than the actuality that some people are
morally wiser than others
that our moral judgments are given by
beliefs
that can be correct or incorrect that
there are reasons to do what's morally
required of us
and reasons against doing what's morally
prohibited of us
that in some way morality's demands are
inescapable
and yet in other and in not yet but and
in other ways
they enjoy a kind of priority over
some considerations like those of
self-interest at least in
a wide range of cases
these and other data are what i regard
as
quite plausible starting points for
theorizing
and i'm not going to try to
you know enumerate all the data in uh in
metaethics
but i think it's fairly uncontroversial
that if you were to if you were to come
to to
to try to identify a long list of those
claims that um inquirers
consider collectively have good reason
to believe at the outset
of inquiry those claims would be handled
really well by moral realism and less
well by
other by other views now again
that's just the start of the
conversation it's not necessarily the
end of the conversation
because it's always open to people
other theorists to say you know what
some of these data are misleading
uh that more wheels and can account for
them doesn't
make it a superior kind of view because
there we should explain these data away
and that's you know if you if you take a
look at the nihilist
they're going to say most of these data
are maybe all of them depending on what
your list looks like
most of these data at least are bunk
they ought to be tossed
they're what are the best stages of
outdated thinking
what are some examples of the data we
have in mind here oh um
ones i was uh ones of the sort i was
just mentioning
namely that um it's possible that some
it's actual rather that some moral
claims are true others are false
but sorry is that data and what's inside
that data is
what i'm asking yeah oh okay it's data
in this sense um
the conception of data i'm working with
is that of
a claim that inquirers consider
collectively
have good reason to believe at the
outset of inquiry
okay that claim is as de as we put it is
philosophically the feasible
right it might not be true it might be
false you know it might be defeated by
but
you need some uh at least equally strong
justification
for thinking that that uh that data
claim that piece of that datum is
mistaken
if you can't provide that then
accounting for that datum is a
constraint
on on the development of the theory
that's going to yield
illumination of the domain in question
okay good
i guess what if i if i have a um
objection maybe this is the right time
to say it
i'll advertise your your books you have
a big book on more realism and then a
little book on what happened
to good and evil which is sort of like
the baby version for those of us who are
not going to become
uh professional moral philosophers and
it's a great read it's very very
readable for people who are interested
in these questions
um and you go through a lot of the you
know possible objections
to this kind of moral realism and i
didn't find my objection in there in at
least the
words that i would use to put it in so i
guess my objection is you you talk about
the
potential objection from disagreement
right just
you you might imagine the fact that just
because people disagree about morality
somehow that undermines the claim that
there are objectively real moral
statements and that that seems pretty
easy to refute
i mean people disagree about all sorts
of things but my
worry is not that there exist
disagreements but that i don't know how
to adjudicate
the disagreements like if someone says
one plus one equals two
and someone else says one plus one
equals three i know how to sit down and
check which one is correct
and if someone says the universe is
expanding and someone else says the
universe is contracting
likewise i knew i know what experiments
or observations to make
but if someone says you know in the
trolley problem you should let the
trolley
hit the five people and then another
another person says no no you should
take an action and just kill the one
person i don't know how to
what experiments to do or what logical
exercise to go through to figure out
which one is correct
is that a is that a reasonable objection
to realism
absolutely it's absolutely a reasonable
objection uh
and it's one of the hardest i think for
realists to handle
once more i want to be clear that
realists
realists have available to them a
variety of different
epistemological strategies for handling
this
for handling this objection
i don't want to canvas them all because
i i don't
i would take too much time be tedious
and i don't endorse them all
yeah no we don't need to get all of them
unless i get the good ones that's right
yeah
but i i want to back up actually and say
something by way of a preliminary and
that is it
as i understand your objection uh
it's basically an epistemological
objection it's that
in circumstances of disagreement let's
call it fundamental disagreement where
the disagreement is not owing to a
mistake
right in uh some in in
about some ancillary factual non-moral
matter which is such that if if some if
one of the parties did this agreement
were to
come to realize their mistake about that
then they'd agree with you about the
morality yeah
um so let's not focus on that sort of
disagreement
in that case uh here's the worst here's
the worst case scenario
that there'd be no way of resolving that
sort of disagreement
what i what i want to say is that even
if there were no way to do that
it's not clear to me why that would
impugn
realism because realism is in the first
instance of a claim a metaphysical claim
it's a claim about what there is namely
a moral reality not of our own creation
explore the possibility that although
here's worst case scenario again we
can't resolve these fundamental
disagreements they're
they're just intractable even in
principle
so suppose that's right it's not clear
to me what that would tell us
about the existence or non-existence of
a moral reality
you might think well if something is
objectively
real or objectively uh true then
in principle there's got to be a way of
convincing
everybody of its truth but
unfortunately for realists we see no
possibility of convincing
everyone of the truth of any given moral
claim
no matter how obvious you know sean and
russ might find it
uh nevertheless there can be some
outliers who disagree
and even in principle we can't get them
over to our side
so suppose that's maybe that's wrong
you know that's the op you know let's be
really optimistic that's wrong we could
get everybody over to our side
but i'm not optimistic like that yeah
you know i think you know
so let's assume that there really is
such a thing as what i call fundamental
disagreement
then the question is what's the fault
what's the theoretical fallout
now there are two possibilities here one
is to say
you know what there is an objective
reality out there
despite our inability to convince
everyone
of its nature or its content
and the other is to say well if we can't
convince everyone in principle
about about this matter then there can't
be
or the best explanation of that is that
there isn't an
objective reality now i i want to hear
more
about why we should go that ladder route
rather than the former because i think
you know if you
if you look at other areas of
philosophical disagreement like whether
there's a god or not
they're brilliant people on both sides
and
uh i doubt you know i'm pessimistic
myself about whether we're ever going to
get consensus
on that matter no matter how you know no
matter how
informed about the empirical elements of
our universe we are
and yet i think in that case although
i'm pessimistic about the possibility of
resolving
fundamental disagreement on this matter
i think it's
pr to me it's very clear that
you should be a realist about this
matter namely
whether god exists or not isn't up to us
i know there are some people who
disagree who think that we create god in
some way or
whether there is a god has in some way
to answer to
our own beliefs about it but i i think
that's really
an implausible view i think either there
is let's just let's
fix our target here an omniscient omni
benevolent
omnipotent creator of the universe
or there isn't and
and it doesn't you know our say so
doesn't make one answer or another
the right answer so that's a case in
which i think it's pretty clear that we
can
we can we should accept realism about
the matter either really theism is true
or really
atheism is true but uh i'm pes
i'm really pessimistic about the
possibility of resolving fundamental
disagreement
yes i mean yeah sorry i do i do
absolutely appreciate that there is a
distinction here between the
metaphysical questions and the
epistemological questions and i guess
the way that i phrased
the worry was more epistemological but i
i don't i don't think that they're
completely independent from each other
either you know if we go if we switch
from the god example to let's say the
cosmological multiverse right let's
imagine there are parts of the universe
very very far away that we can never
observe
but we think that there is a fact of the
matter about
whether or not they're there
whether or not i can convince anyone
else is less important to me than
how do i even decide for myself what to
think about this or how could i
in principle decide if i were granted
omniscience
if i were granted the ability to see
things that are further away then the
speed of light lets me look
then i could actually answer the
question about how do i decide whether
or not there's a multiverse or not
but with the moral questions i don't
even see an in-principle way
of adjudicating these even just amongst
myself they forget about convincing
anyone else like
how do i know when my intuitions point
in different ways
how do i know objectively and and
definitively what the right answer is
how could i possibly know not
realistically but
in potential good i like that way of
phrasing the worry so
if if i could just maybe tweak it just a
little bit
to see if i'm i'm aligned with what
you're
really worried about the thought is this
if moral realism is true there's got to
be some plausible
epistemology that explains how it is
that we get access to
objective moral truths but there is no
such epistemology and therefore moral
realism is false
is that a good way of stating i will i
will tentatively go with that yes
provisionally so yeah so so taken that
way it's an invitation for the realist
to
explain how it is or sorry my kind of
realist non-naturalism because the not
naturalist realist actually has an
answer to you that's uh
at least in principle quite
straightforward but for someone
like me who thinks that morality is
really uh in more
more features are discontinuous
from scientific features of the of the
world
then the whatever standard scientific
means of gaining access to the to the
natural world
are they're not going to be sufficient
they can be enlisted to help but they're
not going to be sufficient to get us
not moral knowledge so we need some
other way of gaining moral knowledge
and again there are different there are
different
epistemologies you know there's for
instance a coherentist epistemology
which i'm not a fan of
but which shares a lot of similarity
with
uh a view that you offered maybe 20
20 25 minutes ago according to which the
way we gain knowledge is
is try to uh
shape our views at various levels of
generality from
judgments about concrete cases to very
large abstract principles and everything
in between to get them to cohere with
one another
in as mutually supportive a belief
network as possible
that's that's a view that was called
reflective equilibrium that is
very likely the uh
well it's the default methodology in
morality it's not one that i'm
a fan of myself and it's got a clear
epistemological correlate in the
coherence tradition
what i would say is here's where you
start in answering questions of the sort
that you're asking
and as you start with your intuitions
you start with the clearest cases
um like genocide's immoral yep
um but then where do you go from there i
guess there are two questions one is
where do you go from there and two is um
how can you
why should you not how can that's easy
enough but why should you
trust your intuitions and both of these
are really good
both of these are really good questions
uh sorry
that was self-flattery because i asked
those questions so
let's assume you were mentioning that
they were questions you didn't
necessarily invent the question
okay and there so this parenthetically
this is the big problem of being a
professional moral philosopher right you
have to be constantly on guard for
people saying well
that's not very moral of you you moral
philosophy
[Music]
well you know the one thing i always
hear not from fellow philosophers
but from other people like at bars or on
used to be airplanes uh when people
would find out what i did
and then they'd find out you know i'd
give them in a nutshell
what my view is about moral realism they
say that's so
arrogant that's so dogmatic and you know
you've got to distinguish between on the
one hand affirming the existence of an
objective morality and then on the other
affirming that you've got all of its
contents that's
anyway sorry i interrupted no um there
are
there what i want to do is i want to be
uh start
by being concessive uh and say that
although i think that intuitions as i've
said a few times now play
um ineliminable vital roles in
our moral in any plausible moral
epistemology and any plausible
philosophical epistemology
i think i want to be concessive and
allowed that a number of our intuitions
can have been distorted by any number of
factors
you know by prejudices that we've imbued
from our culture
or from our parents or friends
various relevant morally relevant kinds
of factual ignorance that we have as a
result of
the time in which we live or the
education we've received or
just lack a candle power up there so
there there are reason one always needs
to
do a check on
you know on whether one's intuitions
have been formed
in uh in a good environment
in in reliable ways the problem though
i'm just going to anticipate a worry
on your part the problem is that when
you do those sorts of checks
you're doing them by reference to other
intuitions that you have
rather than some external world that's
going to give you a
you know if you're a skeptic about the
external world uh
all you got to do is walk into a table
and see oh well maybe i should be so
skeptical anymore there does seem to be
something out there
like that there's nothing out there like
that
if i'm right uh if my picture of
morality is right
when it comes to the moral world there's
no there's no nothing
that's going to impinge on your senses
directly
or necessarily that's going uh that's
going to give you
the sort of check you get to to indicate
that your moral intuitions or your moral
view more generally
is mistaken so i want to allow that
that's
that that's a quite serious challenge
uh to my kind of to
to a moral realist non-naturalist
epistemology
if you've got a naturalist view you're
going to as i said before you're going
to try to assimilate the gaining of
moral knowledge to
the ways in which we acquire non-moral
knowledge um
empirically um so
i you know i don't i don't i wish i had
an elevator speech in which i could
uh address all worries about reliance on
uh our intuitions here well i want
i guess what i want to say is that to
the question where should we start
the answer is with our intuitions that's
that strike us as most
sure about which we are most confident
in i
all the while allowing that these could
be mistaken how is it that we go on to
you to use another word that you've used
but i think you've had in mind
how do we calibrate these intuitions the
answer is we can never
calibrate them in a way such that we can
be guaranteed
to that we are to use your word
decisively
in the no we always have to be
we always have to have a kind of second
order higher order
recognition of our fallibility that even
the things
that we feel or that that's actually the
wrong way to put it
even the moral views that strike us
as so clearly true we have to have a
background
uh open-mindedness about the possibility
that you know what
we could be off on the wrong foot here
but
that's not the place to start the place
to start is with our
very strong moral convictions and then
trying to build from them a coherent
network of
moral beliefs all the while being open
to the possibility that we're mistaken
and
open to hearing from those with whom we
disagree
some reasons why we should abandon our
view
if in the end having heard that we say
you know what
my view still it seems to weather the
storm there
i i think i can handle this then you're
justified in believing
what you believe and if you've if your
beliefs are true and if you've come to
those beliefs on the basis of
the adequate reasons that support them
you've got knowledge
can we be certain that we've ever got
such knowledge
no but that doesn't distinguish moral
knowledge from knowledge in any other
sphere i think that you know
operationally that what you just
described is
incredibly close to my version of
constructivism as well so it's
interesting that the metaphysics
underlying it might be very different
but the uh boots on the ground actions
might be
the same yeah but but i do i think maybe
it'll be helpful for the audience if we
clarify a little bit about that
metaphysics because um
maybe we maybe we skipped over too
quickly the distinction between the
naturalist and non-naturalist
and i even go so far as to talk about
the physicalist way of thinking about
the world i you know i had ned hall on
the podcast
and we talked about humanism versus
anti-humanism about the laws of nature
and there's this there's a human view
that all that exists
is the universe happening over and over
again right you know whatever happens in
the universe that's it and everything
else is commentary and i'm kind of
sympathetic to that although
ned did you know raise some doubts in my
mind uh and then there's this
anti-humane view that the laws of nature
have some umph
to them that they're not simply
descriptions of what happens that in
some sense
bring about what is happening and i i
can't necessarily get my mind around
that but i
maybe dimly see an analogy with
your version of moral non-naturalist
realism because it's you would agree i
think
that uh the the moral
status of a situation does supervene
on the what's physically happening in
other words
if two situations arise at different
parts of the universe but they're
physically exactly the same the same
collection of atoms
assembled into people's doing exactly
the same kind of thing
you would say that inevitably my moral
stance towards those two things
will be the same there's no there's no
extra distinction
i can draw but nevertheless you're going
to say that there is something
important there is some there is some
moral status that is
even though it supervenes on the
physical things happening it's not
identical with them
is that the right construal yeah that's
exactly right that's that's a really
nice way to put it
so this the so-called supervenience of
the moral on the natural
or the non-moral is is just what you
said namely
that if two situations are identical in
in
all non-moral ways then morally speaking
they have to be identical
i believe that and so does almost every
almost every other moral philosopher
it's come under some challenges recently
but it seems to me to be correct and
then the question is
there are lots of questions to ask about
this but let's just focus on the one
that you've asked
and that is that is it the case that in
addition to all that
non-moral stuff maybe it's physical
maybe it's not
just physical is there also some
moral realm that sort of sits on top of
it as you as you will
and my view is yeah there is um
it's not uh then the naturalist realist
says no it's it's not that there's a
there's another layer on top of the
the non-moral or the natural it's all
natural
top to bottom it's just we can carve
that up in different ways
some of the natural has to do with our
psychological states for instance
something natural has to do with
economic phenomena something natural has
to do with
chemistry and some has to do with
subatomic particles
and morality is in there too but it's
all a seamless
a seamless concatenation of natural
features
that together make up the universe i
think there is
a huge you know natural concatenation of
natural features
and that and substances that make up the
universe but i also think
on top of that so to speak there's
morality that can't be reduced
to any of that it does depend on it
uh there's it to me it just wouldn't
make sense to say
that an action was wrong if you couldn't
also point to some natural features of
the action
in virtue of which the action was wrong
so there is a dependence relation
between moral reality and non-moral
reality
but it's not exactly the same reality
there
and that's and that's long been
a worry about my kind of view why
if we can explain everything that needs
explaining just by reference to
uh naturalistic uh naturalistic areas
of investigation then why add this extra
layer
this moral this this layer of moral
features to the universe
and my thought is that's a great
question but it presupposes
that you can explain everything that
needs explaining just by naturalistic
means
and that's and that's something i reject
well i guess yeah and this is where we
are definitely going to differ i think
because in my book the big picture i
tried to make exactly this case that
uh it's kind of a causal closure
argument that if i
am allowed in principle to describe the
universe in the language of fundamental
physics
right bosons and fermions are quantum
wave functions obeying some equations
and that description is in principle
complete
like it it does not need any extra
information
to tell me what will happen within that
language right i will tell you what all
the fermions and bosons are going to do
then how can it be possible that there
is some
reality to extra stuff if that reality
has no
influence on what happens in the world
oh that's a
that's a great question um i i thought
you were going
in a slightly different direction so i'm
i'm a little worried about
causal closure arguments or causal
exclusion arguments because i think
they're going to
in the end exclude too much if we think
that everything
can ultimately be explained everything
that happens in the world can ultimately
be explained
by fermions and bosons then that leaves
little room for beliefs and desires for
instance doing explaining
unless you think that a belief is
nothing other than an arrangement to
fermions and bosons and that's
that's a view that's uh
that some people have held in the
philosophy of mind but not many people
hold
and uh well that's not i don't mean to
argue
by you know by appeal to the majority
that's not
sure yeah it's it's just saying there
might be some
worrying implications of arguing of that
sort of causal exclusion argument that
on the one hand you jettison moral
features
from the from the metaphysics but you
might have to jettison
a lot more that you're less comfortable
jettisoning
that that's one point but yeah i get a
response to that but i want you to keep
going before you before i give it
uh okay um but the the other is
um is that uh
i guess the question uh
indicates a presupposition which is that
everything in the universe actually can
be explained by reference to
fundamental physics and that's just the
assumption that i'm calling into
question
now the le the last part of your
question said well
if things how can we explain what's
going on
or maybe put it this way i think this is
not the way you put it but
why should we posit a realm of features
moral features if they
are unnecessary to explain
what's happening in the world because
why they are necessary because
fundamental physics can explain all that
right so either fundamental physics can
explain morality
in which case you're a naturalist about
things or it can't
but if it can't then why positive
anything that fundamental physics can't
explain i you know what i would say is
that
this this is in this seems to be
uh expressive of what i'll call a
scientistic
view of the world i don't i don't mean
that to be prejudicial
no i get it that's yeah it just one
equals which all
the truths uh in uh that there are
are in principle given by
science of one kind or another it
doesn't have to be physical you know it
could be social scientific
as well as natural scientific you know i
want to leave that open
um to be as ecumenical as possible but
that kind of view is obviously not one
perhaps obviously not one to which i'm
attracted and
i think there is this fundamental
problem with it which is that
the the core scientific claim namely
that
all the truths there are can be
explained by science it's not itself a
truth
that can be explained by science it's
not
or it can't be confirmed by science
it's it's one that it can be if it's
confirmable which i hope it's not
uh is is to be confirmed by philosophy
actually i know that sounds very
imperialistic
but it does it doesn't seem to be that
uh it's it's gonna
that's any science is in the position to
pronounce on it
well i think um so let me take my turn
at giving your side of the argument in
the way that i i'm able to understand it
you know the part of your shorter book
uh whatever happened to good and evil
that i found most
persuasive is the idea that we should
take
morality seriously as real because it
plays an explanatory role
when we talk about um at least the
what happens in the world at the human
level right and that's why we take other
things
to be real because they play some
explanatory role and so and this is what
i was biting my tongue about before
because
i i the way that i would put it is i
wouldn't
say that things like beliefs or purposes
or
morals and judgments are equated with
certain arrangements of fermions and
bosons
but i would say i would say that there
are ways of talking about
certain classes of arrangements of
fermions and bosons they're emergent in
that weak
sense in the same in almost exactly
sorry there's a there is a difference
between morals and
and um purposes let's say i think that
purposes can be straightforwardly
scientific
uh and descriptive of what happens in
the world the
the most compact way of describing with
the physical things going on in the
world might be in terms of purposes
whereas i think that morals are more
subjective than that
but both of them i think um have this
character
that they they can play an explanatory
role
at some level of description but not at
another one and therefore you wouldn't
call them
fundamental pieces of the architecture
of reality
yeah so it's not clear to me why it's
i there's a lot to discuss about
what is to be fundamental if what is to
be fundamental is to be
in some way not equatable identical to
or reducible to uh
something else then i think morality is
fundamental
in that respect right i don't i but
i wanted but people have different views
about what
fundamentality amounts to i want to
allow at the same time
that when something possesses a moral
feature
it does so in virtue of having various
non-moral features
so in that sense some people think well
then morality isn't fundamental after
all
because it's not at the very bottom of
the explanatory
chain so to speak i think it's very far
down at the bottom
but well i guess that's good i mean
let's just
i i want to give you a chance to defend
that but let's just dwell
or at least emphasize how crucial that
statement is i mean
you're saying that on the one hand
morality is
completely tied to the physical
situation in some very real sense
and on the other hand uh it is
absolutely fundamental and necessary to
describe what's going on
yeah that's right i mean think about you
know think about
chemistry for instance you might say
chemistry is you might say you might be
a realist about chemistry
and say we have identified all these
different kinds of molecules we've given
them names but we didn't invent them
i mean we did a few but we uh but you
know
the things early on in the periodic
table we didn't invent those things
uh and uh so they're real
in in a realist sense uh and yet you
might say
nevertheless uh chemical reality is not
fundamental because whenever you've got
a molecule of hydrogen for instance
you've got an arrangement
of atomic material or subatomic material
those arrangements might be different in
different circumstances but nevertheless
you might at least in principle be able
to go all the way down
so to speak to the physical to the
atomic
subatomic level when um
uh when citing some chemical fact
you might be able to do that with regard
to morality but
i want to distinguish uh two things
one is um
matters of specific fact as
instantiations of properties or the
realization of certain features
at a given time from the existence of
those features themselves
now what what i want to allow is that
when a given action say
or when a give is wrong or when a given
intention
or motive is morally admirable
there's going to be some physical stuff
going on
in that scenario you might be able to
describe that scenario
entirely at the physical level but if
you were to do that
my claim is that you wouldn't capture
the morality
of the action so that at this isn't this
is a different way
of insisting on uh
an ontological if you will an
ontological division between moral
features and
physical features right or even natural
features
that that's my view about um about the
relation there whether
then you want um whether you want to
then say
given that for any particular moral fact
about you know that occurs at a given
time in a given place
that there's some physical realization
of that fact
if that's sufficient to show that moral
features are non-fundamental
i can live with that if that if that's
your conception of fundamentality
but what i want to insist on is that
what it is to be something like
to be morally admirable or to be morally
required
is not a physical thing it's not a
physical feature of things yes
okay yeah i think i understand that i
think that's fair i mean maybe to uh
bring the plane in for a landing here um
we can
step outside the meta ethical discussion
we've been having
uh about how one decides or how one
conceptualizes what morality is
and let me ask whether or not the
particular point of view you have on
that of your
uh realist but non-naturalism uh
does affect your actual moral system i
mean does
does that point us in a direction of
deontology or consequentialism or
virtual ethics or whatever other system
you might want to make
no that's the that's the short answer oh
no
that's the that's the uh meta ethics
the meta in metaethics uh it's
i mean that's a great question though uh
most moral realists have
tried deliberately to be as neutral as
possible
about the so-called normative ethical
issues
on the thought that here's the animating
thought
no matter what moral
system is correct um we
realists are not in the business of
trying to answer that question but
rather
talking about are instead in the
business of trying to
talk about the status of that system
yeah and to say that that system
obtained independently of
our attitudes towards it that said
my own view is that if you if you were
to
endorse a kind of uh
a kind of immor what i call immoralist
position
according to which you're celebrating
things like genocide and oppression
and you're denigrating things like
compassion and kindness
that's no that's
that's not the sort of picture that
moral realists have ever wanted to
vindicate
yeah so i actually do think this is why
i think your question's so interesting
i think that at bottom there really has
been though realists have
have not fessed up to it there really
have been
some implicit assumptions about the con
well called the content rather than the
status
of morality that have been driving
realists to defend the views that they
that they have done and in work that i'm
doing
with my collaborators uh john banks and
terence cuneo
we are among the other things we're
doing is we're setting out a view of
moral realism
that builds into it the idea that there
are certain substantive constraints on
what morality
moral reality can look like that that
have to obey these sort of paradigmatic
moral verdicts about say the the
wrongness of genocide
and the rightness of compassion well it
does seem
i mean i i certainly see conceptually
the distinction between
the the meta ethical question and the
the question of actually choosing
how to be moral but on the other hand
doesn't seem a little bit wouldn't it
wouldn't it seem weird
to say that two completely different
notions of what morality
is nevertheless have no impact on
um the morals we think are actually the
correct ones
that would that would just seem weird it
would it would seem
very weird from a constructivist point
of view because what a constructivist is
going to say
i i don't mean that as any sort of
criticism but just
what a constructivist would say is that
the ultimate source of morality
is us in in in some way or other
right and so it um
then you've then you've got a way of uh
nicely pinpointing how it is that uh
we can we can extract if you will or we
can infer
the substance the content of morality
from the med ethic
if for instance what morality is at
bottom
is that set of norms that are mutually
agreed on
by some group say some society or some
culture
then given that understanding of the
nature
and the status of morality you'll be
able to pretty readily
read off you know with some sociological
knowledge what actually
is right or wrong in a given culture
given society
but you can't make that move with
realism
you know with realism it's like we
didn't make it up and so
from that at that that leaves
everything open as to what the substance
or the content of morality might be
nevertheless as i said if you if you
drill down a bit
moral realists whether naturalist or
non-nationalist
would be aghast if the reality who's rea
if the morality whose reality they were
trying to vindicate was as i described
earlier
one that celebrated oppression and
genocide for instance
well i mean uh that doesn't make sense
to me i think maybe
you're not even going as far as you
could go if you think that
our evidence for what is and is not
moral comes largely
from our intuitions then you could say
well that's going to lead us to certain
kinds of conclusions about
what is moral right it will do that's
right but
um once again people will have different
intuitions
um and we've got to recognize the
valuability of our own
so i was i was distinguishing
between two views one of which says that
given
a meta-ethical view that actually
entails
some so-called first order or normative
ethical
commitments whereas on a on a realist
view
it it wouldn't entail the truth of any
normative ethical
view at all it would just um
leave it open as to how we glean get our
evidence for that
and just one other caveat and that's it
my intuition
intuition-based epistemology is again
only one
of a variety of different kinds of
epistemologies most of which we haven't
touched on in this conversation
it's available to realists yeah okay i
mean maybe maybe then
final question sort of a slight
variation on that one if
um if moral realists
are you know have available them in
principle various different moral
systems depending on what they discover
through this kind of thing does your
kind of moral realism
um suggest any way
of people talking to each other
about morality or you know the ways in
which if if we're not sure
what uh morality to pick how we can
learn from others
and uh communicate or is it again sort
of
any possible answer to that question is
in principle compatible with your
realism well
uh the answer i would give is the way
people ought to talk to one another is
respectfully
but that's the snarky un illuminating
answer there is i don't think
that there is a a
determinate method by which
we can uh always make progress
in our discussions with one another
about what's morally right or wrong
i mean people you think think over in in
your
area you know people talk about the
scientific method
might i mean you're a scientist i'm not
my but
i'm skeptical that there really is any
such thing that's character
on your side it's completely crazy okay
yeah i mean we can
we can toss out gender you know very
vague generalities and things like that
on which we can all agree but they're
not in a given instance of science
conflict among scientists
they're not go reliance on that kind of
method is not going to be
sufficient to resolve uh disagreement
it's not a simple algorithm
yeah exactly and there's nothing like
that in philosophy generally
much less moral philosophy in particular
but i
so you know i can say sort of anodyne
things you know keep your
keep an open mind um
you know acquaint yourself with relevant
facts make sure that you're having this
conversation
in a way that isn't triggering really
strong emotions that are likely to
cloud your judgment things like that but
i don't have anything
anything remotely algorithm
like to offer by way of getting from the
intuitions you currently have to
getting uh to a settled view
about which you can have very very
strong confidence
yeah i mean i think that that's probably
a general lesson epistemologically that
uh
algorithms are are hard to get and maybe
not even
the right thing to be striving for in
some of these situations
yeah uh you're absolutely you're
absolutely right about that
all right uh russia ferlando this was
extremely helpful i think that
much like when i talk about foundations
of quantum mechanics and i have my own
point of view but i say like
really my big goal is not to have people
agree with my point of view but for
people to care about the foundations of
quantum mechanics
i think the same thing about morality i
think that you know just be good if
people really
sat down and carefully really thought
about where morality comes from
uh rather than agreeing with my ideas
about it you know let's just take the
question seriously and i think that uh
you're you're doing
great work in in helping people do
exactly that thanks i love that attitude
uh it's been a real pleasure talking to
you
all right thanks take it easy
[Music]
you